tonight new information on a deadly
shooting that police believe may be the
result of a lover's triangle dispute
late last night
officers responding to a home on wakita
avenue near elkhorn and durango
up in centennial hills when they arrived
they found 28 year old shamaya todd
on an upstairs balcony yelling and a
person dead inside the home
todd was later arrested for murder kate
houston is live in the neighborhood with
what may have escalated
into this violence kate
yes i'm just off of chiquita avenue
which is a quiet
family-filled neighborhood but last
night it looked
very different here when more than 40
police officers
responded to this area now here's what i
learned today shamaya todd is the
ex-wife of the man
at that home when officers went inside
they found a young woman
in her late teens shot police say she's
the new girlfriend of todd's ex-husband
three children all under the age of 10
were also inside the home
they're now with child protective
services a neighbor tells me nothing
like this has happened in his 10 years
living in this neighborhood what's
important is we have the safety of the
children and that
whoever did this be convicted but it's a
shame that
they number one they're exposed to it
and now they're going to carry that
forever right i mean they're never going
to forget last night
and i'm sure there's a lot of us we wish
we could
earlier today officers were back out
here canvassing the neighborhood
gathering information and passing out
crime stoppers
flyers now at this time that young woman
has not been identified
todd will make her first court
appearance tomorrow morning at 9.
reporting live tonight in centennial
hills kate houston 8 news now